ni las críticas ni diez semanas de
protestas se frenan la reforma judicial
del gobierno de Benjamín netaniagu en
una sesión que se extendió hasta la
madrugada de este martes en la que en
ese dio una primera aprobación al
proyecto de cláusula de anulación que
permitiría que el parlamento con una
mayoría simple pueda derogar fallos de
la Corte Suprema incluido el veto de
leyes las normas en las que se incluya
esta cláusula quedarían blindadas Aunque
entren en conflicto con las leyes
básicas que en Israel tienen Rango
constitucional A falta de una carta
magna como tal además de los
legisladores también dieron un primer
visto bueno a otros dos proyectos de ley
uno que exige que 12 de 15 jueces del
supremo estén de acuerdo para invalidar
leyes del parlamento que no estén
protegidas por la cláusula y otro que
evita que la justicia pueda declarar no
apto al Primer Ministro israelí
limitando esa decisión al gobierno o al
parlamento Y solo por causas de
incapacidad física o mental con esto
todos los proyectos claves de la
polémica reforma judicial ya han
obtenido una de las tres lecturas
necesarias para convertirse en leyes un
proceso que el gobierno está haciendo a
toda velocidad Pues el ministro de
Justicia yarit levin quiere aprobar todo
el paquete antes de fines de marzo
frente a esto de los movimientos de
protesta prometen intensificar sus
acciones horas después de la sesión un
grupo de manifestantes armó una cadena
humana en la entrada a la oficina de
netaniacu la policía terminó deteniendo
a diez de los manifestantes mientras
este miércoles se prevé un nuevo bloqueo
en el aeropuerto de tenabib antes del
viaje de neta ñá jugaba a Berlín y el
jueves está convocado un nuevo día de
disrupción con marchas en distintos
puntos de Israel